I'm Ryan he's aren't I Marnell hi so
yeah this is kind of crazy title but let
me tell you a little bit about what it
is that we do our job for paypal and
we've been there for a long time now is
advanced technologies so we're in charge
of sort of looking at what we ought to
be able to do to 25 years from now as a
company it means that we get to play
with a lot of crazy stuff but it means
that we get to play with a lot of crazy
stuff that doesn't always work so what
we are what we're here talking about
today is is actually some technology
that we've been working on for a past
couple years that underlies some of the
real-time stuff that you might have
heard mentioned in it in the
introductions a little bit so I'm going
to let our know run through the first
couple railways one thing Ryan forgot to
mention is I'm on the west coast of San
Francisco Ryan's about an hour south of
here in Fredericksburg we've been
telecommuting back forth for over well
we're working together 11 years so we're
kind of a connected device to connected
devices sort of in a virtual environment
all right so here's a scary slide we've
been talking about Internet of Things
for a number of years this is the scary
slide because even yesterday fellow from
Intel mentioned 50 billion devices and I
hope he was talking about 2020 and not
2014 which is where we are today
personally I think that this slope is
actually not as steep as it should be I
think this is going to go parabolic in
the next couple of years for instance
this morning I read that sylvania ostrom
the light bulb company signed an
agreement with belkin cable to do
connected devices on light bulbs so
here's a company an American company
that's been around a hundred years who
would have thought they're going to
change how light bulbs work and they're
basically can be connecting light bulbs
around your house etc etc so this slope
is going to be increasing dramatically
and if you're not ready for the data
ingestion the data analytics today with
the data that you have today we're going
to be swamped we're going to be
underwater with data
in the next two to five years well so he
uh he hands off abstract and esoteric to
me so I'm going to walk walk through
some of this stuff here it's a it's a
pretty dense slide but what we're
talking about today is on is ontology
and semantics but not necessarily in
terms of specifics about a particular
event happening or piece of content
rather we're taking a step back and
we're talking about describing
description itself and so in order to do
that we make a few assumptions here that
I'm going to run through kind of quickly
the first one is the data grows based on
producer content and on consumer need
and rarely if ever by general intent so
I can't think of a single instance where
anybody said you know I think I'm going
to create a data set for everybody for
all the use cases at once just cuz I
don't think has ever happened in fact
we've here lots of people talking about
how unclean the data is all the time
that that's one of their biggest jobs
basically though it boils down to this
producers generate data which happens to
be content in and of itself and so a lot
of the things that we get in IOT
especially our data sets that have
already been around that have been
sitting there so they have a history
they have the actual content they've
been modified over time but they still
sit there in that original context
whether or not that that's normalized or
structured or not it's already there
over time they may make some performance
optimizations for these and they have
the ability to leverage in scituate
Jason sees this is where the case where
you have for example a data set about
you know a particular object and then
you know somebody else is like well we
leverage that object in this other
application so let's sit all the tables
for that right next to it so that they
can access one another so if you happen
to be sort of nearby proximity wise you
get you get to be able to leverage that
and you tend to have local reference
models for that consumers on the other
hand they tend to design data access
based on what they need it for so let's
say there you know somebody's taking
light from this room they may care about
lumens they may care about direction
they may care about shadowing but they
couldn't care less about crystal in the
chandelier so when you grab their that
data set if you are interested in
finding out what kind of chandeliers
were in here all you're going to find
out about is the light itself right
which may or may not I'll be there
that's kind of what all that that stuff
says it also means that you generally
have an application of some sort whether
that's a database or something actually
written or connected device or things
like that that actually understand fill
the blanks in and give you some sort of
comprehension so you get a number back
that's like 1800 it takes an application
to tell you that that's lumens and then
probably takes a description in that
application to tell you that 1800 lumens
is roughly a 75 watt bulb right that
kind of thing the second thing that on
this slide is that data acquisition and
analysis requirements basically multiply
each other's challenges so what we mean
there is for everything that you
increase especially as that parabolic
curve goes up any of the particular
problems that come either from being
able to acquire the data set in the
first place or from being able to
analyze it in the first place amplify
the other one making the problem even
harder right so for example let's say
you've got a data source that you want
that comes to you a hundred times per
minute and now you want to start
sampling it because all your light bulbs
in your house are talking to you and
you're going to start getting 500
samples per minute right well that also
means that the overall data set that
you're looking at went a 55 x larger
right to not only trying to keep the
time frame the same that you're getting
at you're acquiring the data you've
increased the size of the data set that
you're trying to analyze in that same
time frame basically what we're saying
there the one thing that we want to call
out that's really important for what we
do is this bottom the bottom side where
it says parallel time paralyzation is a
huge problem when it comes to internet
of things especially because whose time
are you going to trust right everybody
has time and that's the one thing that
we sort of relied on because it's sort
of this constant we can count on here on
earth the problem is all of the things
out there think that there's a time to
which one's right right when you've got
thousands of events coming to you at the
same time from thousands of different
sources who got there first who sent
first I mean you know all that kind of
stuff makes a difference
I'll boil through this one quickly cuz I
spent too much time on that slide but
but basically I've got a quote here from
from dr. Bell she's a anthropologist who
works in big data at Intel but she says
that look we need we need to start
thinking about sensing technologies as
devices that actually order our world
rather than vices that simply describe
it and once you do that then you can get
some really interesting social and
technological understanding about what's
going on here and that's kind of what
we're going to talk about with this with
this ontology a little bit so some
things some sort of get some
generalizations but one data holds
context it has information that you're
after events also talk about context
they carry it but they in and of
themselves have meaning and that is
important especially as you start to
parallel eyes and get lots more data in
we have to turn our understanding then
of not just the data but also how we go
about analyzing that on its head in
order to be able to pull off things like
real time especially for real time at
the kind of volumes that we're talking
about remember as we you'll see it here
the observation itself is an event so
it's not simply the fact that you you
know that that there's a camera focused
on me as I'm talking I'm talking as an
event but the fact that that camera is
recording at the same time is also
another type of event and it has
different types of information
associated with both of which are
important even though the words I say
are exactly the same in the same context
at the same frequency every time I say
and so finally we need to augment things
as they go as opposed to relying on
centralized data sets to augment our
information we need to augment as things
are flowing by us within the sphere of
influence that we particularly have as
an observer this will hopefully make
more sense in a second do we really need
another ontology to go about doing this
because there's plenty out there yeah we
do and I'm just going to sort of walk
through this and see if I can illustrate
a little bit why you can't judge a book
by it's cover but you can tell much
you're going to cost right there's two
things going on there the book itself is
content right the cost is metadata that
we would associate about the book but
the fact that the to have information
which is different is still important
especially when you're going to try and
modify and understand things coming at
you at one time secondly events
themselves have to be captured as
independent information in order to be
able to understand what's actually going
on so if I say this was the best concert
i've ever heard the event that most
people will think right away is the fact
that there's a concert but you have to
remember that me hearing it is also an
event if i wasn't at the concert i
wouldn't have heard it in the first
place the fact that i said it's the best
concert when somebody else they're
probably left going man i can't believe
i even pay for that right it's two
completely different things even though
the event to the concert hasn't changed
so this this kind of semantics about
understanding what's actually happening
in event goes now this has all been kind
of abstract so we're going to try and
bring it back into the things that make
sense by talking about this idea of
sphere of influence here and it's
basically boils down to this the
transmission of something doesn't just
relay the information but it orders and
gives meanings to it and that in and of
itself increases the comprehension and
the information itself that we gain and
it's important to keep both it's always
important to keep both especially if you
need to do stuff in real time all right
you ready yep all right so we talked
about the sphere of influence everybody
knows what a data lake is it's a Jewish
term for just massive amounts of data
and files we came up with a new term or
maybe it's not new but we decided we'd
call something a data sphere which
basically centers around an event that's
in the center of the sphere and there's
both the temporal and spatial aspect to
the event as it happens so as Ryan
mentioned different people can
appreciate the event experience the same
event in different ways as I mentioned
before I'm from the Bay Area how many
people here from the area great so you
know what happened two weeks ago the
Napa Valley earthquake August
twenty-fourth was a 6.0 magnitude
earthquake 320 in the morning and we can
use that as an illustration of the
actual event that happens so at T 0 an
earthquake happened 320 there's no data
generated at that earthquake at that
point in time because there's no device
there to read it
the device was a seismometer 22 miles
away that was actually reading that
event and gathering data now in parallel
there's no obviously multiple
seismometers everywhere in that in the
valley where this happened I'm just
going to illustrate with one event but
you have to understand that seismic
waves rolling around the ground are
hitting different seismometers at
different times so eventually all that
data has to be correlated back together
to produce the proper maps for the USGS
to actually analyze that data so at time
to the seismometer sends data up to
satellite what happens here is that
event has transported data change the
data it's a message that the satellite
can receive and then the satellite it
basically beams it down to one of the
ground stations where the data gets
transformed again it's a human readable
format with a lot of analytics and
really simplifying this but the
seismologists can actually see the
distance of 6.0 so now we've had three
events on the same sorry three different
experiences of the same event which
happens to be the earthquake and at the
end of it all we have a huge amount of
damage both economically and physically
to buildings and people getting hurt and
this is another event but it encompasses
a larger sphere of influence if you will
so we have you know wineries that are
worried about tourist industry you know
damage to infrastructure etc etc I don't
know how many people felt the event if
you're from the area I luckily was on
east coast at the time but for me
hearing about it you know six hours
later is also another event that I
experienced because I wanted to get home
to understand what kind of damage has
been done and the USGS has a wonderful
website and this is far too I East
Coasters think to California is crazy
but they have a wonderful website where
you can actually go and find out did you
feel it and people can put in based on
zip code if you felt the earthquake and
how moderate extreme or whatever it was
so i quickly checked online when i was
at the airport
checking in to see if my zip code it
felt the earthquake and obviously it had
because I felt a 401 before out of Napa
and it wasn't the most pleasant
experience so one of the big things out
of this so we have five different times
with the same event the data being
generated one of the big things that's
come out of this is and since the eighth
nineteen eighty nine loma prieta
earthquake that happened which is 25
years ago this is the second largest
quake that's our first largest quake has
happened since then in northern
california in 25 years the USGS has put
out 400 more sensors into the ground
right our communication system is
completely different everybody has a
smartphone or phone cell phone we now
have video cameras everywhere there's
security cameras in businesses in homes
etc etc but we have what we call an IOT
phenomenal with wearables so this is a
graph that I pulled up from a blog by a
company called jawbone that has a
wearable called up and this is a great
analytics slide that actually shows you
that people wearing these up devices
wearables the blue line shows you that
people in the close proximity to the
earthquake were woken up at ninety
percent ninety percent those people woke
up at the time of the earthquake or
slightly thereafter so it's basically a
spatial and temporal analysis going on
here because people in San Jose which is
you know hundred miles away didn't
really wake up at all and you'll also
see that people in San Francisco where
I'm from woke up in everyone immunity
back to sleep whereas the people in Napa
were quite concerned about what's going
on so the IOT wearables analysis for a
particular event shows you that all this
work can be done so how does this relate
back to paypal so Ryan and I've been
working on a project for the last year
and which we term systems intelligence
and systems intelligence basically is
around how do we understand and analyze
our ecosystem and our ecosystem being
our data centers the applications in it
data centers the servers and the data
centers the interactions between servers
and and people and are all our IOT
devices that are out there which are
basically our mobile apps on cell phones
our point of sales terminals everywhere
on the offline world so we have to
understand how all those interactions
occur now we basically took four streams
of data application logs which we
generate out of thousands and thousands
of application servers machine data out
of the servers themselves data center
metrics like community temperature power
and social media so we take all this
information together and try to make
sense of it and understand what happens
when something happens like an
earthquake event how does that interact
with everything that happens in our
application in our ecosystem so we're
doing this all in real time okay we're
very unique from all the talks I've
heard today and some of the other of
toxin and conferences we've attended
we're fairly unique in doing this in
real time and I don't mean two minutes
later I'm talking with in real time so
within milliseconds of what's happening
and the other problem that were
challenged with is what are we up
against in real time well we're doing
three million events a second today now
given that parabolic curve is going
higher and higher in the next few years
this number is going to be very
astounding for us I mean it's it's a
challenge as it is today but it's going
to get larger and larger we're going to
be doing 200 million by milly bite sorry
megabytes a second which literally
translates to about 30 terabytes an hour
of data ingestion and anna analysis in
real time 20 megabyte of machine
telemetry data there's 50,000 metadata
relationships we did this last year and
it's basically a graph of all the
relationships together it's not a like
psychedelic a molecule or anything like
that and it represents one hour of time
there
and there's also obviously changes in
social media happening here people are
on Twitter tweeting about paypal if we
put on a new release tool either say oh
that's great or they'll say well this
doesn't really work for me so there's
obviously changes happening in a social
aspect and of course we've got an
increased global customer service aspect
to this as well so we're basically
taking all this data ingesting it
analyzing in real time and try to make
sense of it so that we can save on power
we can we can you know watch servers
move up and down for power usage because
right now everything's on the same of
these light bulbs are on all the time
and from our perspective Internet of
Things inside a data center for instance
we can actually start shutting down VMS
and spinning them back up as the need
for that application increases and
decreases so you know what what we're
going to show you here well i'll go
through this quickly and this is the
same exact thing but but from the
perspective of one of the events that we
we actually have here i'm going to go
through it quickly basically in this
case x 0 is us releasing a new a new
update to want to one of our features
for example in this case ACH transfers
are transactions and buying generally at
t1 which is about a minute later in this
particular case we see a spike in time
outs from connected devices around the
world whether that's divided you know
swipe card things at like home depot it
could be a terminal it could be a here
device we also about 10 minutes after
that detected an increase in IV our call
volume coming into our customer service
centers and then our engine that's been
correlating all this data here says you
know what we've we've noticed that all
of this stuff is relevant and it goes
back to t0 which happens to be this API
release and so we then automatically say
roll that code back right and that and
then again that happens to our command
and control and orchestration system so
that by the time at t3 we've already
understood what was going on this this
was a processing could take actually
literally day
is sometimes in the past and we bet
again we've been able to get it down and
into real time t1 and t2 in this
particular taste take longer to occur
but our understanding of what's
happening in t3 is actually done in 250
milliseconds or less and then we're able
to effect that roll back so that within
within about a minute and a half of
having detected the roll back the need
for roll back we've actually pushed a
code back to get things off this is a
little bit about the actual ontology
itself it's really hard to read and we
don't have a whole lot of time to go
through it but basically i'm going to i
define for different things here and
i'll just get to a slide with them all
on there we have a concept of scope
which is probably the most important it
defines things like whether you're an
element yourself whether you're an event
a particular node a pool for us is just
a collection of nodes a pod appointed
deployment is a collection of pools and
global means everywhere in the world so
basically it's your reference idea and
then by combining latency dependency and
what we call impacts you can describe
any event in the world whether it's an
earthquake event like we talked about
before or if it's a case of in this
particular case our application in voice
web in is actually connecting to a
database here's what you see it's not
it's not an error message this is an
okay thing that happened we get them all
it's important though I think to realize
that as we as we go through this the
idea that i think is central to what
we're trying to do is by taking a step
back from the actual data from taking a
step back from trying to clean it up and
make it tell us what we think it ought
to tell us because i think that's one
thing that data analysts bring to the
table that they sometimes forget about
you have a question in your mind you
want an answer to and therefore you're
bending your will to the data set in
order to be able to understand a truly
parallelized IOT world especially one
that you can't predict with information
coming from all different sources you
have to take yourself out of that
equation at least in the data
acquisition phase especially if you want
to do things in real time because you
simply don't have time to go well maybe
if I bring in this other
data set over here I can augment that or
you know what if I clean this up so that
it fits nicely into this little bin
it'll tell us I don't know if you if you
notice for example most of what we do
here is simply hashes of information
right because we realized at the end of
the day the machine learning was correct
it figured out the right thing we people
care about what it actually said
computer couldn't care less so for us
the hashes absolutely just as good as
the original it data and it's awful lot
faster and so that that's kind of what
we're bringing to the table you can you
can get more about it these are all the
different types of event scenarios I
don't have time to go into the specifics
but you can you can ask a question about
them if you want and that that they can
cover but but by doing this by taking
this sort of second order approach and
redefining how we think about data and
how we codify it as it as it flies past
us we may have a chance at being able to
comprehend what's going on in IOT but as
long as we're leaving stuff in a data
warehouse somewhere we've already lost
that's it thanks thank you